[Music]
previously on model lifestyle so I made
it to South Korea this is my model
apartment you might recognize him I'm
gonna add it here is the Giorgio Armani
campaign he's also a musician he's a
rapper willing and able to make up a bit
the controller would let me say both how
much is it so now I'm gonna show you
guys how software looks like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys I am very excited because I
have a really cool job tomorrow so I'm
flying tonight to jeju-do Island and
we're gonna do a video there for black
desert it's a very famous Korean game
that they might translate into English
and so yeah I'm gonna shoot a video game
thing no I'm not exactly sure what its
gonna be like but I'm gonna take you
guys with me so we can go and see what's
gonna happen
let's go this is a team I'm going with
to Jeju Island is that is that correct
juju Jeju okay that I pronounced it so
it is a beautiful place it is like the
Hawaii yeah right
not them not like Howard but a little
bit yeah similar all right yeah and
we're gonna do this kind of job is a
video job for a mobile gaming right old
black desert I think it's very famous
here in South Korea and so that's what
we're going to show you guys introduce
yourself to my friends over here so hey
my name is Elizabeth I'm from France
what am I
[Music]
I'm gonna get my acoustically Lucas name
dijo good
shouting till the angles one small you
know my real name no one is supposed to
know not even the professor's friends
and hi my name is Joseph I manager I'm
from oh yeah yeah of course
[Music]
so he's making sure we're not gonna be
crazy or doing anything stupid on the
job and we eat well our plane is waiting
we're gonna start boarding in five
minutes check it out
that is our plane right there yeah check
out the video
[Music]
someone's free space here it's almost
like only to us here this blind
the worst thing if you're tall and
you're flying just no space no leg space
here so we made it we're here it was a
very very long life of only 40 minutes
but we are here with the team and we're
on the way to this is the rest of the
crew here they eating already this is
Korean BBQ that's we're gonna have
they're already waiting for the meal and
checking out the menu there to see what
are we gonna have for dinner all right
so this is like the kind of dish we're
starting now there's a lot of side
dishes this is kimchi this is almost in
every single meal that I eat here in
Korea right famous traditional Korean
fruit kimchi and this is the pork this
is how to do the barbecue here
so this is how you have to eat the
Korean barbecue
you put a meat in there you dip it and
then you put I don't know what is that
but you put that on it all right
next part is a beef give it a try
how was it for tomorrow so we're in the
hotel room finally done with dinner done
with everything now I can go to sleep so
if we have only problem we contact you
guys yeah
all right cool I'll see you later bye
nine eight
where am I again nine eleven I think
yeah you're right
oh you're next door all right here we
are all right so this is my room for the
night
not bad all right
[Music]
good morning mislead more
so just add some breakfast
and then we're gonna go make up a little
bit later and then that's it
everybody is camera shy in the morning
okay we're starting the make up how long
have you been a makeup artist 10 years
that's good experience ten years makeup
water efficient professional let's do
this
all right so makeup is done so hair is a
little bit messy because they want me to
walk in the wood and look like I'm very
tired and I've been working for a long
time so we're gonna go we're gonna
change into the outfits and then we're
gonna start the job
[Music]
alright so in the car we are on the way
to the locations around 20 to 30 minutes
drive alright we're here at the location
this is the crew and in a few minutes
we're gonna start we're gonna go into
the forest are we gonna start the video
this is the kind of forest where they
make scary movies so this is where we're
gonna do our first scene where I'm just
gonna walk in the forest it's the first
scene knowing but it's kind of exciting
this is intro yeah it's the intro you
know have some smoke there in the
background
holy here's the feeling is a little bit
not like you're afraid there's something
out there but I don't know what it's out
there yeah
[Music]
so you also get a storyboard this is the
storyboard we did this scene or just
walking looking around now we're gonna
go for the close-up
Daniel is checking
he's good to see to play back and I know
more so I see it there's something out
there what is that
[Music]
so we're having some learn some kimbap
kimbap kimbap how do you feel now we are
having a little bit break and now drone
is coming for shooting us oh cool drone
yeah so get some air footage that's why
here we're setting up okay there's a lot
of work right it's not just a few
crewmen it's how many people do you
think is here oh like 40 40 people
working well normally people only see
the video when it's finished rather they
don't see what's going on behind the
scenes yeah so this is cool all right
this is the second scene we're gonna sit
here with the fire over here okay
hi they feel you know warmer warmer
laying on me I think the fire but you've
got their help XO yeah sure who gave it
to you
ask me the question secret and act in
front of the camera but nothing my
camera haha
so Joseph you want to join us here it's
a little bit dark so you guys cannot see
it that clearly but we are having dinner
and it's around 11 o'clock at night but
the whole crew is here and we are eating
here in the forest in the middle of
nowhere we have a bit of a break they
setting up this scene there we're gonna
get some close-up they're gonna focus on
her so I'm just gonna be my my back of
what the back of my head is gonna do the
acting but now they're gonna come here
but you guys cannot see it in the video
but it's actually called that's why
we're wearing these guys and also yeah
your friends yeah these are super hot
friends for life I guess we do nice how
do you feel about the video is it the
next scene let's go we are almost
finished that she's doing some scenes
with Elizabeth and the client can sit
over here or there or here and then they
can look at us acting and Elizabeth is
right over there
at the fire doing her acting and I'm
next
you saw the duck night
[Laughter]
action
tell me about the bachelors
he was
until
[Music]
she told you get introduced now
connected well
canary sciatica integer audio suka Wow
done comes Amrita thank you thank you so
what just happened
136 yeah Wow let's go back to the hotel
so we're done we go back to the hotel
all right let's go so finally we made it
back to the hotel it is 220 in the
morning so it's been a very long day but
it's been a successful day and we've
done it